if by some unknown means  that we don't even know  you get the presidential election thrown  out  nancy pelosi becomes president it's not  donald trump the supreme court will not  be reinstating donald trump no one will  be reinstating donald trump i know steve  bannon knows this horrible person but  he's not this stupid so why is he saying  it maybe he wants clicks and this gets  him clicks i don't know  maybe it's a signal to people to prepare  for another violent coup attempt  neither is a great scenario i think the  coup is worse from those two options  simply trying to monetize a dumb  audience is one thing but trying to  weaponize that audience into attempting  another riot i think is far worse  quite frankly it's not like there have  really been major consequences at least  yet for the rioters so why wouldn't you  go for another coup attempt if steve  bannon tells you that maybe it'll work